Vielen Dank.
Wie heißt du?
Eva Schmidt.
Können Sie mir Ihren Voll- und Magen am Land verstellen?
Gut probieren.
Eva und Schmidt mit GT.
Frau Schmidt.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 33 Jahre alt.
Nein, Entschuldigung, 53.
Wie ich?
51.
Und wie groß und wie schwer sind Sie?
Ich bin 160 groß und 80 kg schwer.
Okay, gut.
Und was kann ich für Sie zum Fraschen mit was für Sie zum...
Ich habe Luftnot seit ein paar Wochen.
Wir haben Luftnot.
Wie lange haben Sie das?
Seit ein paar Wochen.
Kann man genau bei zwei Wochen?
Ungefähr.
Wie lange haben Sie das?
Wenn ich treppen steige, ja, wenn ich mich anstringe.
Okay, dann habe ich Ihre Luftnot.
Ich treffe nur bei Belastung, z.B. bei Treppensteigen
oder in Ruhe auch auf.
In Ruhe auch, aber nicht viel.
Aber wenn ich mich anstringe, wird das sehr stark.
Okay, z.B. wie viele Treppen können Sie steigen,
ohne Luftnot zu wegkommen?
Vier, fünf Treppen.
Stufen, nicht treppen, Stufen, Entschuldigung.
Fünf Stufen.
Wie viele Metzer können Sie aufwohlen?
Das weiß ich nicht.
Beim Laufen merke ich das nicht so stark.
Es ist mehr, wenn ich treppen steige.
Haben Sie Wurstschweine?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Okay, diese Luftnot ist immer dabei
oder manchmal sind Sie nicht beschwerdenfrei.
Bitte?
Manchmal sind Sie beschwerdenfrei
oder haben Sie immer diese Luftnot?
Durchgehend.
Ich meine, ob ich die Luftnot durchgehend habe?
Okay.
Oder intermittent?
Nein, ich habe ...
Mir geht es allgemein nicht gut.
Ich habe auch in Ruhe, aber nicht so stark Luftnot.
Aber es wird mehr, wenn ich mich anstringe.
Okay, haben Sie Wurstschweine?
Bitte?
Haben Sie Wurstschweine?
Wurstschweine? Nein.
Ich habe Wurstschweine.
Danke.
Haben Sie andere Beschwerden?
Wie bitte?
Haben Sie andere Beschwerden, wie Ewigkeit oder Erwirkung?
Nein, Übelkeit und Erbrechen habe ich nicht.
Wie ist Ihre Appetit?
Normalerweise ist mein Appetit gut.
Das merken Sie ja.
Aber es ist so, dass ich momentan, weil es mir nicht gut geht,
habe ich ein bisschen weniger Appetit.
Normalerweise habe ich einen guten Appetit.
Okay.
Okay, haben Sie in der letzten Zeit Gewicht so oder abgenommen?
Nicht seit.
Seit wann wird mit S ausgesprochen?
Zeit wird immer T, T, S, Zeit.
In der letzten Zeit.
Jawoll, genau.
Letzte Zeit.
Sehr gut.
Was habe ich in der letzten Zeit entschieden?
Gewicht ab oder zugenommen?
Ich habe Gewicht zugenommen.
Wie viel Gewicht habe ich?
Gucken Sie sich mal meine Beine an.
Ja, okay, haben Sie eine Schwellung?
Sehen Sie, wie dick meine Beine sind?
Nein, ich muss gucken.
Meine Beine sind richtig dick, so dick,
dass ich Probleme habe, mit den Beinen zu laufen.
Ich habe eine Schwellung an die Beine.
Sie sind drückbar.
Bitte?
Weg drückbar.
Was meinen Sie damit?
Komprimierbar, kann man sagen.
Was heißt komprimierbar?
Okay.
Haben Sie schon einmal probieren,
in Ihrer Beine zu drücken?
Womit?
Mit Ihrer Finger.
Warum soll ich das?
Nein, ich nicht.
Soll ich das mal machen?
Okay, alles klar.
Ich kann das mal probieren.
Sie meinen also, ob ich mit dem Finger
in meine Beine in die Schwellung reindrücke
und dann weggedrückt werden.
Haben Sie das so gemeint?
Ich habe es jetzt verstanden.
Wenn ich mit dem Finger in die Schwellung reindrücke,
dann entsteht ein Loch.
Ein Loch.
Es ist wegdrückbar.
Haben Sie Probleme mit Wasserlassen?
Ich muss macht viel Wasser lassen.
Nachts muss ich viel Wasser lassen.
Wie viele müssen Sie?
Nicht wie viele, sondern wie oft müssen Sie aufstehen?
Oder wie oft müssen Sie Wasser lassen?
Wie oft müssen Sie Wasser lassen?
Wie viele müssen Sie?
Ich muss 2-3 Mal aufstehen.
Das ist sehr unangenehm.
Haben Sie Probleme mit Wasserlassen?
Nein.
Ich glaube, Sie müssen nicht so laufen.
Ich glaube schon.
Aber Sie problemen oder durchschlafen?
Ich glaube, Sie müssen nicht so laufen.
Ja, wie soll ich durchschlafen,
wenn ich 3-mal aufstehe, um Wasser zu lassen?
Ich verstehe.
Haben Sie Nachts?
Nein.
Ich habe die Erkrankungen von denen ich wissen sollte.
Was meinst du?
Ich habe Blutdruck.
Ich habe eine hohen Blutdruck.
Ich habe eine Zuckerkrankheit.
Was noch?
Ich nehme 2-mal am Tag 1000 Milligramm
wegen dem Zucker ein.
Ich nehme ein Kandesatran.
16 Milligramm.
Ich nehme den Blutdruck.
Ich nehme ein Kandesatran.
16 Milligramm.
Amludipynt.
Ich nehme den Blutdruck.
Was ist das?
Das ist sehr gut, genau.
Das ist die Diarrätik.
Kann ich sagen, wie viel Milch?
16 Milligramm, einmal morgens.
Dann habe ich gesagt, das mit Formientausen Milch, morgens und abends.
Und dann nehme ich noch am Lodipin 5 Milligramm, morgens und abends.
Und in der Pommit?
Ich weiß nicht mehr, wie viel Milch haben das.
Einmal am Tag nehme ich das, ein morgens.
Okay, ich bin gut.
Wurden Sie schon einmal operiert, oder?
Nicht, dass ich wüsste, eigentlich nicht, nein.
Aber Sie gegenehm sind Alergie?
Nickelalergie, hollenalergie und Staub.
Wie sehen Sie aus?
Was meinen Sie damit?
Wie reagieren Sie?
Wie ich reagiere?
Ich habe Heuchenupfen, meine Nase läuft ständig.
Ich habe Nickelalergie, wenn ich mit Nickel in Kontakt komme, dann habe ich Juckreit an der Haut.
Okay.
Haben Sie eine Notfallmedikamente dabei?
Was meinen Sie bitte?
Ich habe das nicht verstanden.
Okay, haben Sie gegeben Ihre Allergie eine Medikamente?
Sie meine Notfallmedikamente, meine Allergie.
Ja, so ist das nicht. Ich brauchte bis jetzt keine Notfallmedikamente.
Okay.
Ich nehme nur, wenn Blütezeit ist, wenn Polen Zeit ist, dann nehme ich Antislaminika ein, dann nehme ich Lora...
Lora...
Lora Tidin?
Lora Tidin, genau. Lora Tidin, 10 mg nehme ich ein.
Aber nur vorübergehend.
Okay.
Und Cortison musste ich bis jetzt auch nicht einnehmen.
Okay, gut.
Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ich gefalste aber nicht frisch.
Ja, bei Gelingen halt, bei Feierlichkeit.
Und Rauchung wie?
Früher habe ich geraucht, ja.
Aber ich habe nach 10 Jahren Rauchung aufgehört.
Also haben wir 10 Jahre lang geraucht, ja?
Ja.
Und wie viele haben Sie Alkohol?
Seien Sie noch mal bitte? Was haben Sie gesagt?
Wie viele Zigaretten haben Sie pro Zeit geraucht?
Ja, genau.
Wie viele Zigaretten kann ich Ihnen nicht sagen?
Packung, als Packung kann ich Ihnen das sagen.
Ich habe ungefähr eine Packung am Tag gebraucht.
Okay.
Frau Schmidt, haben Sie regelmäßig an Ihrer Frau oft erst besucht?
Frau oft?
Ich würde es nicht sagen, eher nicht.
Haben Sie Periode?
Nein, nicht mehr.
Okay.
Und habe ich freundlich Leben Ihrer Eltern noch?
Nein, kein Problem.
Sie waren ja auch schon älter.
Okay.
Und warum haben Sie die Gestaltung?
Natürlicher Tod.
Meine Mutter ist an Krebs gestorben
und mein Vater an natürlichem Stolz.
Und gibt es wichtige Erkrankungen in Ihrer Familie?
Ich möchte Krebs fallen.
Ja, meine Mutter.
Okay.
Was haben Sie gesagt?
Mieren.
Haben Sie Geschwester?
Ja, habe ich.
Eine Schwester und ein Bruder.
Sind Sie gesund?
Ja, die sind beide gesund.
Meine Schwester hat Diabetes.
Sag mir mal so, meine Schwester hat ein metabolisches Zünderum.
Ihre Bruder ist gesund, ja?
Ja.
Okay, gut.
Und was sind Sie vom Beruch?
Ich bin Ärztin.
Das ist schön.
Und meine Frau, die Frage...
Super.
Meine vorbundene Frage,
ich habe auch Arbeit, aber...
Nein.
Nein, weil ich momentan im Urlaub bin.
Aber wenn ich arbeite, habe ich sehr viel Stress.
Super.
Und Sie sind verheiratet?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, ich habe zwei Kinder.
Sind Sie gesund?
Gott sei Dank, beide gesund.
Okay.
Und...
Ich frage mich, ich würde gerne wissen,
müssen Sie zu Ihrer Haus-Trepenszeige?
In meinem Haus, ja.
Wir haben ein Haus mit zwei Stockwerken.
Aber den zweiten Stockwerk benutzen wir nicht.
Ich muss immer ein Stockwerk hoch.
Okay.
Und wie viele Treppen?
Ein Stockwerk, wie viele Treppen?
Ja.
So 13, 14 Stufen.
Okay.
Wir haben einen Geldwerksmarkt mit vier, fünf Stufen.
Aber wie Luftnoten?
Genau. Ich frage die Treppe nicht auf einmal hoch.
Ich muss immer Pausen machen.
Okay.
Aber früher ging das.
Das ist neu. Das ist seit zwei Wochen erst.
Ich habe jetzt auch ein bisschen Luftnoten.
Okay.
Ja.
Ich habe Luftnoten.
Ja, machen Sie was.
Okay. Dann möchte ich kurz unterbrechen.
Ich möchte gerne Ihre Sauerstoff-Kontrollierung und
evansib-Brauchung.
Sauerstoff-Setigung ist 93.
Sauerstoff-Setigung ist bei Raumluft 93%.
93.
Okay.
Dann würde ich gerne Ihre Masal-Sauerstoff geben.
Bei 93%.
Können Sie machen? Wie viele Liter?
Ja, drei Liter.
Vielleicht zwei, vier Liter.
Okay. Also zwei bis vier Liter über die Nase.
Okay, danke.
Ja.
Aber meine Luft ist immer noch nicht besser.
Wie?
Meine Luft ist nicht besser durch den Sauerstoff.
Okay.
Dann ich kann das war so lieb.
Ich zeige.
Eigentlich wird nicht besser.
Deswegen können Sie besser finden.
Ich bin nicht viel besser.
Okay.
Dann möchte ich gerne mit Nutzmask-Sauerstoff geben.
Vielleicht das geht besser.
Haben Sie mal auf meine Lunge gehört?
Nein, aber natürlich ich würde gerne eine körperliche
Umteil suchen.
Dann hören Sie mal bitte auf meine Lunge.
Ich höre auf.
Also Sie hören Vasal anzunehmen,
das ExpIrium und dassel der Geräusche.
Ja.
Was ich höre, dassel der Geräusche.
Und Vasal anzunehmen, das ExpIrium.
Expiem ist verlängert.
Er verleichtert, ExpIrium.
Okay.
Ich würde gerne Ihnen in unserer Stationen ...
Auf die Überwachungsstation? Danke.
Ja, genau.
Und dadurch können wir ihre Therapie besser weiter machen.
Und ich würde gerne für Sie eine Kardiologiekonsil anmelden.
Nein, kein Konsil anmelden. Das gibt es in Deutschland nicht.
Das muss wir jetzt alles selber machen.
Okay.
Dann ich würde gerne für Sie eine Ekokardiographie führen.
Was vorher? Vor der Echokardiographie? Was vorher?
EKG Schreibung.
Und ich würde gerne...
EKG ist alles in Ordnung.
Okay.
Das ist zumal gut. Sauerstoff-Setigung ist jetzt unter 2 Liter Sauerstoff bei 98 Prozent.
Also können Sie weiter machen.
Okay.
Ich würde gerne Blutort nehmen.
Ihre Heiz-Enzyme und Rokonien kontrollieren.
Okay. Sie dürfen weiter machen mit der Anamnese.
Okay.
Freilich mit.
Hab ich alle wichtige E-Pomotoren zu ihr?
Habt ihr sie noch fragen?
Oder möchtest du sie noch etwas sagen?
Nein.
Okay.
Dann möchte ich mit meinem Oberarzt besprechen.
Dann werden wir noch mal sprechen mit Ihnen.
Okay.
Das heißt, muss ich im Krankenhaus bleiben oder kann ich jetzt nach Hause gehen?
Ja, Sie müssen ins Krankenhaus bleiben.
Muss ich auch an der Überwachungsstation bleiben?
Wie lange muss ich auf der Überwachungsstation bleiben?
Ich kann das dafür nicht genau sagen.
Ich muss so weisen.
Wovon hängt das ab, wie lange ich auf der Überwachungsstation bleibe?
Das hängt von Ihrer Ergebnisse.
Okay.
Das heißt, ich warte, bis die Ergebnisse da sind.
Ja.
Das heißt, ich bleibe so lange an der Überwachung,
bis die Untersuchungen alle durchgeführt sind und die Ergebnisse da sind
und dann wird entschieden, ob ich abkann
oder weiter auf der Überwachungsstation bleiben muss.
Ja, genau.
Alles klar.
Sagen Sie das mal bitte.
Ich muss noch 10, können Sie noch mal sagen?
Nein, Sie müssen jetzt sagen.
Je nach der Untersuchungsergebnisse kann ich Ihnen sagen,
ob Sie im Krankenhaus bleiben oder stationär aufnehmen.
Okay, ja.
Genau.
Es hängt von den Untersuchungen befunden ab.
Wie lange Sie auf der Überwachungsstation bleiben müssen?
Stationär bleiben müssten Sie auf jeden Fall?
Aber Überwachungsstation hängt von den Untersuchungen befunden ab.
Okay.
Wovon hängt das denn?
Hocam, Musik und Terbjesin, diese Geschenke können wir als als Geschenke...
Alles klar.
Okay.
Hab ich Kollegen oder Kollegen noch andere Fragen?
Ich habe einige Fragen.
Ich mache zwei Fragen, Osmanice.
Ich bin Skandalist.
Ich habe zwei Fragen.
Okay, also können Sie flachlegen beim Schlafen?
Nein.
Nein?
Oder wie viele Kissen benutzen Sie?
Ich habe zwar ein Kissen, aber ich habe mein Kissen gewechselt.
Ich habe jetzt einen Hohenkissen genommen.
Okay.
Ja.
Zweite Frage?
Also, haben Sie Probleme beim Einatmen oder Aussatmen oder beiden?
Beides.
Beides, okay.
Ich denke, drei bis vier noch Fragen stellen.
Ja?
Kollegen, aber...
Ich habe eine Frage.
Bitte schön.
Also, Frau Schmidt, haben Sie Herzrasen oder Herzstolpen?
Ja, habe ich nicht.
Wie viele Mal haben Sie das gehabt?
Haben Sie...
Wenn ich mich anstrengen habe, habe ich das.
Im Moment nicht, im Moment nicht.
In Ruhr habe ich so Aussätze.
Okay.
Herzstolchalt.
Und wenn ich mich anstrengen habe, habe ich Herzrasen.
Okay, ich höre es.
Und seit zwei Wochen haben Sie Herzrasen.
Herzstolpen, oder?
Ja, seitdem ich die Beschwerden habe, habe ich das.
Genau.
Seitdem ich die Luftnot habe, das ist alles zusammen aufgetreten.
Okay, okay, ich verstehe.
Und waren Sie deswegen beim Hausarzt?
Nein, ich war noch barkeiter.
Ich dachte, das geht von selbst weg.
Okay.
Okay, danke schön.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Bitte schön.
Seit wann haben Sie Bluthochdruck und Zuckerkrankheit?
Und nehmen Sie Ihre Medikamente regelmäßig einnehmen?
Noch mal, den letzten Satz bitte noch mal.
Das war kaum medikallisch falsch.
Ja.
Okay.
Nehmen Sie Ihre Medikamente ein, geht nicht.
Nehmen Sie Ihre Medikamente regelmäßig ein.
Sagen Sie das mal?
Genau.
Ich nehme eine Medikamente immer sehr regelmäßig ein.
Da achte ich auch drauf.
Ja, nehme ich ein.
Okay, seit wann haben Sie?
Der Bluthochdruck, den habe ich aber schon lange.
Den habe ich noch zehn Jahre.
Mehr.
Okay, danke schön.
Achso, noch was?
Hallo?
Ja, nicht Zucker, bitte.
Zucker gibt es nicht.
Zucker, Zucker, Zeit, Zucker, Zeit, Zucker, Zeit, nicht Zeit, sondern Zeit und Zucker, bitte.
Zucker.
Richtig.
Zeit und Zeit.
Ja, Zeit und Zeit.
Können wir was sprechen, oder?
Zeit, der Unterschied oder was?
Ja, Zeit und Zeit.
Ja, Zeit ist, ich habe seit sieben Uhr beschwerden, seit.
Ja.
Und Zeit ist die Zeit.
Wir haben jetzt die Zeit, Uhr.
Und der Unterschied ist, es ist bei seit sieben Uhr zum Beispiel, Bery,
seit es geschrieben ist, aber die Deutschen sprechen das es am Anfang ja aus seit.
Und Zeit ist das Z.
Okay.
Zeit, Zeit, sehr.
Fragen?
Also ich finde, an einem Nestig hätte man noch mehr fragen können, aber alles gut.
Ja, aber Auslöse gibt es bestimmt auslöse, nicht gefragt.
Ähnliche Beschwerden, nicht gefragt.
Die Beschwerden akut oder langsam sind aufgetreten, nicht gefragt.
Haben Sie ähnliche Beschwerden zum Beispiel?
Schon mal gehabt?
Ja, schon mal gehabt.
Ähnliche Beschwerden schon mal gehabt? Nein, habe ich nicht.
Das ist das erste Mal.
Gibt es 500?
Ja, Belastung.
Belastung.
Akut oder langsam die Beschwerden aufgetreten sind?
Sind die Beschwerden akut oder langsam aufgestreten?
Oder sagen wir so, sind die Beschwerden akut aufgetreten oder haben sie langsam zugenommen?
Das ist besser.
Ja.
Ganz ehrlich.
Akut oder plötlich.
Plötzlich und akut ist das selbe.
Also das kann ich gar nicht mehr genau sagen, aber ich glaube eher, dass das plötzlich aufgetreten ist.
Ich möchte eine Frage stellen.
Ja, ich möchte eine Frage stellen.
Akut ist auf Deutsch oder Papi-Grift?
Nein, akutes Fachbegriff ist nicht Deutsch und das heißt plötzlich.
Plötzlich ist Deutsch.
Aber mit Patienten Deutsch sprechen?
Ja, also die meisten Patienten verstehen ja akut, aber wenn die es nicht verstehen, klar.
Also ich versuche immer, wenn ich mit den Patienten spreche, immer einfache Wörter zu benutzen, ganz einfache.
Und Impfstatus? Nicht gefragt?
Impfstatus.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, ob das so wichtig ist.
Corona Test gemacht oder nicht?
Ach so, das finde ich auch eine gute, sehr wichtige Frage. Ja, stimmt.
Covid-Test habe ich nicht gemacht? Nein, Covid-Test habe ich nicht gemacht.
Impfstatus?
Ich bin geimpft zweimal. Also Covid meinen Sie, Covid-19.
Kinderkrankheiten, alle...
Kinderkrankheiten, ja, in Deutschland immer.
Grip Impfung zum Beispiel.
Grip Impfung? Dieses Jahr habe ich mich nicht grip impfen lassen, nein.
Influenza-Impfung habe ich nicht, nein.
Okay.
Können Sie Pneumococco...
Bitte?
Antipyro...
Nein, langsam. Erst mal überlegen, was Sie wissen wollen und langsam fragen.
Sie müssen eine korrekte deutsche Frage fragen. Es geht um eine FSB-Prüfung.
Also nochmal.
Okay.
In Deutschland können Sie Pneumococco wachsen.
Was heißt denn wachsen? Wissen Sie, was wachst du einst auf Deutsch?
Wachst heißt Ada.
Was heißt wachsen? Ich wachse, hier, ich bin schon gewachsen. Soll ich noch wachsen?
Ja, nicht...
Impfung?
Impfung, ja.
Erst mal überlegen, genau, was man sagen will. Was meinen Sie jetzt?
Jetzt sagen Sie, dass du das verstehst.
Okay. Haben Sie Impfung gegen Pneumococ?
Pneumococcan.
Ja, sehr gut, das kann man sagen.
Haben Sie eine Impfung gegen Pneumococcan? Nein, habe ich nicht.
Danke.
Ich denke, alle Fragen gestehen halt, Herr Kollege. Können wir jetzt als Gechef anfangen?
Ja. Sie hat jetzt genug Zeit, um nachzudenken.
Jetzt muss Sie gut, gut, gut, gut Gespräche führen, mit Arzt zu Arzt.
Merve, das muss jetzt gut sein.
Das ist jetzt wirklich Luxus gewesen, so lange Zeit zu überlegen.
Okay, fangen wir an.
Bitteschön.
Aber ich weiß, dass das schwer ist. Ich habe heute auch Prüfung gehabt.
So ist das halt, ist egal. Aber ich habe mit mir keiner geübt.
Okay.
Meine Oberärztin, ich würde gerne heute über meine Frau...
Ich meine Oberärztin, nicht meine Oberärztin.
Frau Oberärztin.
Man kann sagen von mir aus Frau Oberärztin, man kann auch sagen den Namen einfach Frau so und so,
aber ist okay, man kann jetzt auch sagen, Gesang ist mal Frau Oberärztin, ja, okay?
Okay, ich würde gerne heute über meine Patientin wegzuholen.
Wir haben die Zeit dafür.
Längen Sie mal los, ja.
Okay.
Meine Patientin ist Eva Schmidt.
Meine Patientin ist Eva Schmidt, geht nicht.
Meine Patientin heißt Eva Schmidt?
Oder es geht um die Patientin Eva Schmidt?
Wann ja. Es geht um die Patientin Eva Schmidt?
Oder es geht um eine Patientin von mir, sie heißt Eva Schmidt, aber eine Patientin,
meine Patientin ist Eva Schmidt, geht nicht.
Okay. Es geht um die Patienten, Eva Schmidt.
Sie ist 53 Jahre alt.
Und einmal zur 60, Grosse und 80 Kilo.
Okay.
Von Anfang an, noch mal von Anfang an.
Ja.
Okay. Es geht um die Patientin Eva Schmidt.
Eva, Eva.
Eva Schmidt, sie ist 53 Jahre alt.
80 Kilo Gramm schwer und 1 Meter, wechstig, groß.
Sehr gut. Eben haben sie nämlich gesagt, große.
Das geht gar nicht. Sie ist 1 Meter, 63 groß.
Persekt, super. Okay.
Kann man weiter machen.
Und Frau Schmidt, es teilt sich heute bei uns,
wenn wir seit ein paar Wochen bis zur Hände...
Was?
Seit ein paar Wochen, ja, richtig.
Ja, seit ein paar Wochen bis zur Hände...
Bitte was?
Und die Dispne.
Dispne?
Und sie berichtete, sie habe diese Dispne sowohl bei Belastung
als auch im Ruhe.
Zu dem gibt sie das Meist...
Zu dem.
Ja.
Dann den.
Zu dem.
Nicht zu dem.
Zu dem gibt sie an, dass sie meistens 4, 5 Treppenstufen steigen kann.
4, 5 Treppenstufen steigen kann? Genau, ja.
Und was passiert...
Ohne Dispne zu bekommen.
Ja, sehr gut. Super, ohne Dispne zu bekommen. Sehr gut.
gab sie an, dass sie Ödeme in ihrer Bein habe.
Diese Ödeme ist wegdruckbar?
Ja, das dürfen Sie so nicht sagen. Darüber hinaus hat sie angegeben,
dass sie Bein-Ödeme hat. Sie müssen das gesehen haben. Darüber hinaus hat sie.
Okay.
Ja, weil das hört sich so an. Patientin hat das gesagt,
aber ich habe mir nicht die Mühe gemacht zu gucken. Nein.
Ich habe das jetzt gesagt, weil wir sie mich nicht sehen von Namen.
Aber Sie müssen, wenn Sie sich der Oberrat sagen,
darüber hinaus hat die Patientin Bein-Ödeme, die wegdruckbar sind.
Nicht die Patientin hat gesagt, sie hat Ödeme.
Die Patientin hat gesagt, dass ihre Schwester tot ist.
Das geht. Aber die Patientin hat gesagt, dass die Ödeme hat.
Geht nicht. Sie müssen das angucken.
Dann müssen Sie sagen, die Patientin hat Bein-Ödeme.
Sie haben sich der Körper leicht untersucht.
Okay.
Die Patientin hat gesagt, dass sie Bein-Ödeme.
Ja.
Darüber hinaus hat sie gesagt, dass sie Bein-Ödeme.
Nein.
Das muss man so sagen. Nicht die Patientin hat gesagt, sie hat Bein-Ödeme.
Die Patientin hat gesagt, dass ihr Mann dick ist.
Den haben sie nicht gesehen. Das müssen sie glauben.
Aber alles andere müssen sie gucken beschwerden.
Okay? Okay.
Okay, die Patientin hat Bein-Ödeme.
Wo? Und wo hat sie die Bein-Ödeme? Einseitig oder beidseitig?
Ich hab nicht gefragt.
Nicht gefragt? Nicht? Sie haben's geguckt. Sie müssen's gesehen haben.
Okay, beidseitig.
Sie haben's gesehen. Beidseitig.
Ja, die sind beidseitig.
Das haben sie nämlich vergessen zu fragen. Das ist wichtig.
Warum ist das wichtig zu fragen, ob die Ödeme beidseitig oder einseitig sind?
Äh...
Warum ist das wichtig?
Zu gucken, ob das einseitig oder beidseitig ist. Warum?
Für die Adnose?
Ja, warum? Was ist der Unterschied von einseitiger und beidseitiger?
Was ist eine Beidseitige in der Regel, eine beidseitige Beinwähnstellung?
Woher kommt das?
Äh... Heizkrankung...
Herzinfizient.
Herzinfizient, ne? Bein-Ödeme, beidseitige Herzinfizient, oder...
...Potegurin.
Potegurin ist verloren über die Niere, Nierekrank.
Entweder Nierekrank, Herzkrank oder ganz selten Lympho-Dimit, beidseitig.
Das heißt also, warum ist das so wichtig?
Weil was kann es sein, wenn es einseitig ist?
Und das eine ist ganz schlank, nur das eine ist dick.
Was kann das sein?
Das kann ein Trauma sein.
Einseitig Ödeme, Trauma.
Ja, aber Trauma ist ja etwas, was nicht so schlimme Nachwirkungen hat.
Was ist schlimm einseitig? Woran muss man denken?
Was muss man ausschließen bei einer einseitigen Beinschwellung?
Was kann eine einseitige Beinschwellung sein?
Eine Trombose, eine tiefe Beinwähnung Trombose.
TVT sagt man dazu.
Eine tiefe, wähnendrombose. TVT.
Ja?
Und warum ist das so wichtig, dass man weiß, ob das eine TVT ist?
Was macht denn eine TVT?
Lungan emboli.
Aha. Und was für Beschwerden hat die Patientin,
um noch mal die Beschwerden zurückzukommen?
Was hat sie für Beschwerden?
Lufnot.
Das heißt, für uns ist es wichtig,
ob sie beidseitige Beinschwellung hat oder einseitige.
Das haben Sie eben nämlich nicht gefragt.
Das ist die wichtigste Frage.
Warum?
Weil Sie sich schon mal ausschließen können,
wenn die Beidseite gespannt sind.
Das heißt natürlich nicht, dass Sie in beiden Beinen
selten Trombosen, ich weiß sie muss man nachgucken.
Aber einseitig ist es schon mal offensichtlicher für eine
Trombose predisponierter als beidseitig.
Ist wegen.
Und wenn Sie Lufnot hat,
müssen Sie sich das angucken, die Beine.
Beidseitig oder einseitig?
Okay, alles klar. Weiter.
Sie klackte immer, da Sie macht.
Was erlassen muss.
Sie klackte.
Nichts.
Bitte.
Nocturie.
Nocturie, kann man in die Oberersteam,
können Sie mit den Fachberichten aus der Oberersteam
können Sie alles sagen.
Sie hat Nocturie 2-3 Mal.
Oder Sie muss nachts 3 Mal Wasser lassen.
Sie muss nachts 2-3 Mal aufstehen.
Um Wasser zu lassen.
Oder Sie hat 3 Mal Wasser lassen.
Ganz einfach.
Kann man sagen, wie man will.
Okay.
Und bitte eine Sache, bevor Sie es vergessen.
Sie sagen immer, oder du sagst immer, da.
Da gibt es nichts.
Das.
Sie klackte über das, wie man viel Wasser lassen muss.
Okay.
Sehr gut.
Sie haben in der letzten Zeit so genommen.
Ja, genau.
Und woran liegt das Ihre Meinung nach?
Was meinen Sie, warum Sie es zugenommen hat?
Ja.
Wasser.
Wasseransammlungen.
Genau.
Wasseransammlungen oder Wassereinlagerungen in den Beinen.
Ja.
Sehr gut.
Super.
Ja, möglicherweise.
Das ist die Ursache.
Okay.
Ja.
Das.
Bittem.
Beckens.
Hat sich für Tony.
Und.
Diabetes Melitus.
Die.
Das.
Bittem.
Morgen und Abend und also Operation.
Keine hier.
Ja, wir wurden keine Operation.
Noch mal bitte wiederholen.
Wir haben keine Operation.
Sie haben keine Operation oder sie wurde keine Operation geht nicht.
Sie wurde nicht operiert vielleicht.
Ja, wir haben keine Operation.
Operation haben, ne?
Sie haben keine Operation ist gut.
Und wir haben Nikol Polan und Schutzaapolergie.
Und sie reagiert auf Nikol und Häusschlopfen.
Sie reagiert auf Nikol mit Kuritus.
Okay, das hat Kontakt der Matitis.
Aber Fäuschnupfen hat sie wegen der Polnalergie.
Und Häusschlopfen.
Sie reagiert auf Polan.
Und sie nehmen die Polnalergie.
Sie regnet es.
Loratidin, 10 Milligramm Stein.
Dauermedikation?
Bei Bedarf.
Nein, nonphobicains.
Immer dann bei Bedarf sagen.
Wenn die das nicht dauerhaft einnehmen, immer bei Bedarf sagen.
Das heißt, wenn sie es braucht.
Okay, Loratidin bei Bedarf.
Vorübergehend, was bedeutet?
Vorübergehend heißt, sie nimmt es ein und nach 10 Tagen setzt es ab.
Und das andere ist, sie nimmt es immer ein, wenn sie es braucht.
Okay, danke schön.
Sie zählen gelagenpil alcohol.
Und die Glaubung, wo der verneint.
Haben Sie mich nicht gefragt?
Nein, ich habe nicht gefragt.
Ja, keine Frage.
Sie nimmt keine Drogen ein, das stimmt schon.
Okay.
Sie sind extra open.
Ich habe das akustisch.
Extra open.
Extra?
Extra raucheren.
Entschuldigung.
Ja, sie ist extra raucheren.
Richtig, Entschuldigung.
Sie hat den Päckchen gelauft.
Ja, sie hat 10 Päckchen gelauft.
Sie hat 10 Päckchen gelauft.
Sie hat 6 Päckchen gelauft.
Sie hat nur 6 Päckchen gelauft.
Ich habe 6 Päckchen gelauft.
Sie hat die dragonischeistance verfolgen.
Ich habe in ihren Jahren 6 Päckchen gelaufen.
natürlicher Tod sagt, das glaube ich. Details wollen die eh nicht wissen.
Ja.
Die haben amnestischen Angaben deutzt und amessen.
Ja, aber Schwester, Schwester, Diabetes mellitus und Metabolisches Syndrome.
Ja, ja, ihr ist der, der ja Metabolisches Syndrome und Diabetes mellitus 2.
Mhm.
Und der an den nestischen Angaben deutzt und amessen auch eine chronische
Coronareheizkrankheit, also Heizinsuffizien und die Virenziadiatnose kommen im Metat.
Lunganembony, Moccalein Pynomony.
Sie haben nicht gefragt, ob Sie Fieber.
Gut, sie hat gesagt, sie hat kein Fieber. Passt das?
Nein, kein Fieber.
Ja, passt das zu einer Pneumonie? Weiß man nicht, kann ja sein.
Vielleicht hat es eine Stormspurmini, das wissen wir nicht.
Kann da ein bisschen sein.
Kann sein.
Ja, als die Prinzipialdiagnose können Sie alles aufzählen.
Das ist okay.
Ja, ist okay. Pneumonie.
Unwahrscheinlich, aber kann sein, ja, kann sein.
Und vielleicht ein kurzer Coronaeisendron.
Das haben Sie als erstes schon gesagt.
Die Diagnose sprechen eher für eine KKK, haben Sie gesagt.
Ja.
Herzunsoffizienz, Lungenembolie.
Was noch?
Pneumonie.
Kurzer Coronaeisendron, habe ich gesagt.
Haben wir doch schon gesagt.
Haben wir alle schon gesagt.
Haben wir schon gesagt.
Aka-Haka nimmt alles schon mit ein.
Aka-Kurnaesendron, KKK.
Was noch?
Passt das denn zu einer KKK?
Sie hat ja gesagt, sie hat keinen Druck auf der Brust.
Sie hat nur Luftnot.
Passt das zu einer KKK?
Nein.
Doch, warum?
Passt das zu einer KKK?
Nee.
Warum?
Warum muss die Patientin keine Beschwerden haben?
Die muss keine Beschwerden haben.
Gibt es?
Die Patientin hat die Patientin der Name.
Nicht sagen.
Stopp.
Nicht.
Okay.
Sie musst es selber wissen.
Warum muss die Patientin keine Beschwerden haben?
Melve.
Uhu.
Okay.
Ja.
Welche Patientin haben stumme Myokartinfarkte?
Myokartinfarkte, die keine Beschwerden machen.
Welche Patientin haben die?
Wenn sie Diabetes mellitus haben.
Hat sie Diabetes mellitus?
Ja.
Und Patienten, die Diabetes haben, die langjährigen Diabetes haben,
die haben nur Neuropathie, die müssen keine Schmerzen haben.
Ja, genau.
Das heißt, die Beschwerden, sie könnte auf jeden Fall eine KHK haben.
Sie hat Belastungsdüsbne.
Warum?
Weil sie Luftnot bei Belastung hat.
Das spricht irgendwas Kardiales.
Ja, natürlich kann das auch was anderes sein.
Natürlich muss man trotzdem Analog in den Bulli ausschließen.
Das sind die zwei Diagnosen.
Klar.
Aber sie hat auch Bein-Ödeme.
Das passt alles eher zu einer Kardial-Dekompensation.
Und dann muss man ja wissen, warum ist die Kardial-Dekompensiert?
Warum?
Oh, Sache zum Beispiel, Ichhime.
Ichhime ist was KHK.
Erste Differenzialdiagnose.
Kardial-Dekompensation, Herzinnis und KHK.
Das war sehr gut.
Ich wundere mich, wie du da drauf gekommen bist,
ob du es nur geraten hast, weil du eigentlich gar nichts gefragt hast.
Du hast nur gefragt,
hätten ich dein Ja?
Und dann auf einmal war ich die Diagnose.
Ja, aber ich habe den Frist nicht schon gelassen.
Du bist geraten?
Nein, nein, alles gut.
Das war sehr gut.
Also, es war die richtige Diagnose.
Das war auch das, worauf ich hinauswahl.
Aber weiter.
Wichtig ist, aber ich habe noch gesagt.
Wichtig ist, du hast das zum Nachdenken, als wir gequatscht haben.
Also, wichtig ist nicht die Diagnose wirklich.
Das muss nicht richtig sein.
Die Differenzialdiagnosen sind wichtig.
Blumenembolik kann sein.
Pneumonie kann sein.
Eine wichtige Differenzialdiagnose, die man auch immer im Kopf haben soll,
die gefährlich ist, lebensgefährlich ist.
Ja, arteriale Hypertonien, was kann sie noch haben?
Sie kann Hypertion-Syvent-Kleisung haben.
Wie war denn der Blutdruck?
Haben Sie den Blutdruck gemessen?
Nein.
Die Patientin hat gesagt, mir geht es nicht gut.
Und dann schreibt man als Allererstes bei einem Diabetiker,
egal welcher Patient,
EKG ist das einfachste, was man machen kann.
Sauerstoff-Sättigung dran.
Blutdruck messen, EKG.
Ich nehme den Patienten an die Überwachung.
Okay?
Okay.
Speibe ein EKG
und höre auf die Lunge.
Wenn sie eine ausgeprägte Spastik hat, kann es einfach sein,
dass es auch eine exaktive COPD ist, mit Rechtsherzbekompensation.
Dann hat man auch Beinröde.
Das ist jetzt alles sehr komplex, aber das kann alles sein.
Ja, je mehr Differenzialdiagnosen Sie aufzählen,
die logisch damit zu tun haben, desto mehr denken die Prüfer,
oh, ja, die hat es kapiert.
Verstehen Sie das, ich meine?
Ich weiß, dass das schwer ist.
Ich habe mich heute ganz blöd angestellt bei der Prüfung.
Es waren so einfache Fragen.
Ich musste zehn Stunden überlegen, was man damit ...
Oh, man, ich wusste noch nicht mal, was der von dir hören wollte.
Ich verstehe, dass das so ist.
Aber deswegen üben wir ja.
Mit mir hat keiner gehypt.
Ich musste das ganz alleine machen.
Okay, so, ne?
Das ist okay.
Ja.
Und jetzt weiter.
Wie grenzen wir das jetzt alles ein?
Jetzt haben Sie die Verdachtdiagnose.
Ich konnte eine KHK, es könnte ich Chemie, KDLD Kompensation sein.
Wie gehen Sie vor?
Was machen Sie jetzt als erstes?
EKG haben Sie ja schon gestritten.
Sie schreiben an EKG und nehmen Blutab.
Haben Sie ja schon gesagt, haben Sie ja schon gesagt.
Ja.
Was, bestimmen Sie denn im Blut, im Labor?
Ja, im Labor, ich würde gerne im Heiz-Enzyme kontrollieren.
Welche?
Sika, Sika, MB.
Ja.
Und BMP.
Was noch?
Althroponin.
Welches?
Was ist Troponin?
Ist das ein Herz-Enzym?
Protein.
Ja, es ist ein Protein.
Das ist ein Protein.
Das ist kein Herz-Enzym.
Sagen Sie einfach die Herz-Biomarker.
Ich kontrolliere die Herz-Biomarker.
Das ist ein guter Ausdruck für.
Dann kann man, muss man nicht sagen Enzyme,
dann, ich mein, Sika, Sika, MB ist ein Enzym.
Troponin ist nicht ein Enzym.
Dann kann man sagen, ich kontrolliere die Kavialen Biomarker.
Das sind ja Biomarker.
Ja?
Verstehen Sie?
Ja, verstehe es.
Und was noch?
BMP ist ganz wichtig.
NT pro BMP.
Das NT pro BMP.
Proben wir nach.
Das bestimmen wir.
Warum?
Also, um Myocardinfarkt auszuschließen?
Nein.
Ah!
Das BMP nicht beim Myocardinfarkt.
NT pro BMP.
Yes, it was not.
Okay, Lungenemboli.
Nein.
Ja, Lungenemboli, das stimmt.
Aber warum ist es bei der Lungenemboli erhöht,
das NT pro BMP?
Warum?
Ja, Rindwerke.
Rindwerke.
Ja, natürlich.
Bei der Lungenemboli ist das rechte Herz belastet.
Was passiert?
Das Lungenemboli erhöht.
Das ist nicht suffizient.
Auch erhöht.
Das heißt, wenn sie eine linke Herzinsuizenz hat,
das können wir damit sehen.
Ob sie eine rechte Herzinsuizenz kann man sehen.
Deswegen machen wir das NT pro BMP.
Und aber auch bei der Lungenemboli.
Eben wegen der Rechte Herzbelastung.
Okay?
Okay.
Was machen Sie noch an Werten?
Jetzt haben Sie.
KHK, also Althus-Coronazyndrom haben Sie versucht,
die Lungenemboli zu erhöhen.
Was können Sie noch?
Es gibt doch einen bestimmten Wert,
was man machen kann für Lungenemboli.
D-Demeyre.
Das müssen Sie sagen.
Wofür ist das noch wichtig?
Was haben Sie gleich mit?
Wann ist die D-Demeyre noch erhöht?
Bei der Lungenemboli und?
Verordnen die Sektionen.
Ach so, okay.
Ja, nachlesen, okay, das ist wichtig.
Verordnen die Sektionen.
Und welcher Marker ist noch wichtig bei der Lungenemboli?
Aber das haben Sie schon gemacht.
Ich will es nur wissen von Ihnen.
Die D-Demeyre.
Pro BMP ist wichtig.
BMP.
Ne, pro BMP haben wir doch schon.
NT pro BMP haben wir doch schon.
Das ist wichtig für die Lungenemboli und das Troponien.
Beides ist erhöht bei der Lungenemboli.
Und beides, wenn es erhöht ist,
ist ein schlechtes Zeichen.
Okay.
Okay, was machen wir noch?
Ja, Kalium.
Ja, was noch?
Was noch?
Kalium, Natrium.
Ja, Kalium, sagen Sie doch einfach Elektrolyte.
E-Elektrolyte.
Ja, Elektrolyte, Blutbild.
Blutgas, Angräte.
Erst mal Blutbild, ne, wir sind noch im Labor.
Blutbild, was noch?
Die Gerinnung?
Mehr ne?
Gerinnung, Gerinnung, Parameter.
Die Gerinnung, Grinnungsparameter, genau.
Was noch?
Erinnungsparameter.
Der gute Erinnungsparameter.
Die Leberwerte.
Und was noch?
Der GA.
Und TSH.
Das TSH würde ich immer mitmachen.
Warum?
Wir haben eine Begegnung.
Ja, genau.
Es kann ja sein, die hat ja gesagt,
sie hat ein bisschen Herzrasen, wenn sie treppen hochsteigt.
Vielleicht hat sie auch Paroxysmalithakrikadien,
Vorflimmern zum Beispiel.
Und dann kann man das TSH ja machen.
Und wenn es verändert ist, kann man T3
und T4 nachmelden, gell?
Was könnte denn die Ursache sein,
nämlich, weil wenn sie ein Vorflimmern
ein Tachrikadiss hätte, was wäre die Ursache dafür?
Was ist der Grund für ein Tachrikadissflimmer,
Vorflimmer?
Warum mache ich das TSH?
Ich werde sie aussehen.
Genau, so ist es.
Okay, super.
Okay, jetzt haben sie Labor gemacht, haben sie super gemacht.
Sie haben das TSH vorgesagt,
er sagt immer vor heute, er soll nicht vorsagen.
Also, Aterilöbe GAA, ne?
Eine Blutgasanalyse können Sie noch machen.
Okay, sehr gut.
Okay, der ist jetzt am Monitor, sie haben das EKG geschrieben,
sie haben Blut abgenommen.
Und im EKG haben wir gesagt, man sieht nichts.
Auf keine Tachrikadies, sie hat ein Sinuschritmus,
auch kein Blockbild.
Ja.
Und jetzt ist es so,
dass sie ja,
was machen Sie weiter?
Was machen Sie jetzt?
Was machen Sie jetzt, was machen Sie jetzt?
Denken Sie, Sie haben gedacht,
es ist eine KDLE LKP.
Was machen Sie noch als Untersuchung?
EKG, Labor
und Lunge,
wie sehen Sie die Lunge noch,
was müssen Sie für eine Untersuchung machen,
für die Lunge noch?
Nein, ganz correct.
Richtig, genau.
Was sehen Sie denn im Röntgen Torhax?
Stauung, ja. Also, genau Stauung, ob man Stauung sehen kann,
pulmonalvenöse Stauung, ob man das sieht oder Lungen-Ödeme, das ist ja schon ein bisschen
fortgeschritten, wenn sie Lungen-Ödeme hätte, weil es sich nicht
flächert, sind Krälungen-Ödeme, da wird es ja ein bisschen anders, er hätte sich stärker
beschwerden. Aber egal, ist gut, genau das wollen wir sehen und was wollen wir
noch sehen? Sie haben gesagt, einen Differenzial-Logenose haben Sie noch gesagt.
Kinomonie. Was sieht man noch?
Infiltration, kräftig. Infiltrate, das heißt, wir können an der Lunge jetzt
ergusstau und Infiltrate zum Beispiel sehen. Was kann man noch sehen in der Lunge?
Was können wir sagen? Muss ja nicht, aber kann ja sein.
Eine Raumforderung zum Beispiel, kann man auch sehen.
Das heißt, mit dem Röntgen-Tor, das kann man schon mal Infiltrate ausschließen.
Man sieht den PV Stau, EKG haben wir gesagt, also, dem haben wir zum Beispiel
auf jeden Fall nicht gesehen, das heißt, wir haben Zeit, wenn dann ist es ein
End-Steam oder ein Akkus-Tronasendruck, da muss man ja keine EKG-Vernomen sehen
und Labor haben wir auch schon gemacht. Und was können Sie in der Zeit jetzt noch
machen, wenn Sie warten auf die Herzentzüme oder auf die Unpropomien,
um zu gucken, ob das vom Herzen kommt. Eine wichtigste Untersuchung kommt jetzt.
Wenn Sie sagen, das ist kardial bedenkt und wenn Sie sagen, das ist an den
Herzgefäßen, was gucken Sie denn jetzt nach? Welche Untersuchung?
Was machen denn die Kardillogen?
Ich komme noch an die Eugrömpfe.
Vorher noch eine einfache Untersuchung.
Echokardilopie?
Ja, genau. Warum?
Warum?
Punkt von Kanzler.
Ja, natürlich. Was sehen Sie denn?
Sie sehen überhaupt, hat der überhaupt eine Herzentzüme?
Ganz einfach unter so, das sieht jeder.
Sehen Sie sogar, Punkt ist gut oder Punkt ist schlecht, das linke Herz.
So, und was können Sie noch verurteilen?
Das rechte Herz, das ist ganz wichtig.
Sie sehen, ob der Patient, Sie müssen nicht wissen, was Sie sehen.
Oder das wissen Sie nicht, ob der Patient Rechtsherzbelastungszeichen hat.
Rechtsherzentzüme, oder sagen Sie einfach Zeichen für eine Lungenembolie
für eine Rechtsherzbelastung.
Es gibt bestimmte Zeichen, wo man sehen kann, das Herz, das rechte Herz
ist überlastet.
Dann denken, wissen Sie, es könnte eine Lungenembolie sein,
weil das rechte Herz sieht auffällig aus.
Oder aber das linke Herz, dann wissen Sie,
das ist einfach eine Herzentzüme.
Das ist das, wenn die Pumpfunktion nicht gut ist.
Es muss nur Ursache haben.
Ich hebe mich zum Beispiel, also KHK.
Und wenn die Patienten eine neue eingeschränkte Pumpfunktion haben,
wegen die das, was Sie gesagt haben, eine Koronadengrafie.
Und was sehen Sie noch im Echokardiogramm?
Das ist wichtig.
Die Pumpfunktion, Lungenembolie, also Rechtsherzbelastungszeichen,
Hinweise für eine Lungenembolie und Klappenveränderungen,
natürlich Herzklappen.
Wenn er eine hochgradige Autonklappensthenose hat,
dafür ist sie noch zu jung, die ist 53 Jahre alt.
In der Regel haben das ältere Leute.
Aber hochgradige Autonklappensthenosen,
die kompensieren auch ganz schnell,
die haben auch Luftnot bei Belastung.
Verstehen Sie das schon mal, ne?
Kann alles sein.
Ich sage das nicht, dass Sie das jetzt alles wissen müssen.
Das ist viel.
Wenn ich ganz ehrlich sein soll in der Prüfung,
habe ich mich so blöd angestellt.
Ekk gezeigt.
Verstehen Sie, ich weiß das.
Ich verstehe das jetzt.
Ich verstehe, dass es nicht einfach ist.
Aber mit mir hat keiner geübt.
Ja.
Ich verstehe das jetzt.
Aber die Diagnose ist genau das, was ich im Kopf hatte.
Nur ich hätte mir gewünscht,
dass die Anamnese etwas besser ist.
Haben Sie Schmerzen auf der Brust?
Haben Sie ...
gibt es in der Familie Herzinfarkte?
Ja, das zum Beispiel.
Familie, Familie, Anamnese, das zum Beispiel ist wichtig.
Wenn man rauchen, ja klar, also habe ich ja gesagt,
rauchen, Bluthochdruck,
Übergewicht, Diabetes,
der hat ja schon vier Risikofaktoren.
Also ist das schon naheliegend,
dass das in Richtung Kaka, oder ich schäme mich es.
Aber Sie haben das gut gemacht, ne?
Lungenembolipneumonie, Sie müssen noch nur überlegen,
was mache ich jetzt als Diagnostik,
damit ich das auskriege, Entzündungswerte zum Beispiel.
Ich hatte ja die Entzündungswerte für die Prämonie,
Biomarker für die Akute Coronasundrum, ja.
Und D-Demäge, dann habe ich sowohl die Autostiktion mit drin,
und ich habe auch die Lungenembolie mit drin.
Ja, okay.
Und dann, wenn das alles muss, macht man noch einen Röntgen-Turaks,
und dann macht man noch einen Herzultraschall.
Und dann entscheidet man,
und in dem Fall genau richtig,
macht man eine Herzkatheter-Untersuchung,
und die war pathologisch, standgekriegt.
Und dann, die Pumpfunktion war nicht stark angeschränkt,
sie kriegt dann Herz- und Sozienstherapie,
und dann ist alles gut.
Wenn ich jetzt frage,
was Sie für eine Herz- und Sozienstherapie jetzt kriegen müssen,
ist das zu viel?
Ja, das ist nichts für die Fachsprachentrüfung,
das ist zu viel verlangt.
Mahamudra.
Ja.
Das ist schon eine Kenntnisprüfung, ne?
Nein, nicht Kenntnisprüfung.
Ich kann sagen, wie ich.
Ich stellte meine Herz- und Sozienstherapie ein.
Ich frage jetzt.
Mezobiloto.
Können wir einsetzen?
Und Ace-Hemma.
Bitte?
Ich würde das nie wieder hören, das Wort.
Es gibt kein Ace, ACDC oder was?
Nein.
AC-E-Hemma.
Ace-E-Hemma.
Wieder, das gibt Schädel,
ich stammt Kopfabbruch.
Ace-E-Hemma.
Oder?
Etwas besser.
Ace-E-Hemma macht ein bisschen Reizhusten,
die anderen machen keine Reizhusten.
Welche Medikamente machen keine Reizhusten?
Macht Ace-E-Hemma.
A-T-1-Hemma.
Ja, also genau.
Beta-Blocker, Ace-E-Hemma
oder A-T-1-Blocker, was noch?
Die Übertrika.
Welches?
For Semids.
Für die Herzensuffizienztherapie
nach den ESC-Lightlinien,
nach den Lightlinien, nach den Guidelines,
Spirinolakton.
Für die Herzensuffizienztherapie.
Was noch?
Es geht AC-E-Hemma.
Ganz wichtig, das, wenn Sie, bitte.
Super.
Bestanden.
Rundum bestanden.
Ich freue mich.
Das ist genau das, was momentan jeder hören will.
SGLT-2-Hemma.
Ja, die sind super.
Das ist das.
Also,
Herzensuffizienztherapie,
4-Säulen-Therapie.
Beta-Blocker, A-T, also A-C-E-Hemma, A-T-1-Blocker.
Oder das Allerneuste, ich weiß nicht, ob Sie das wissen müssen,
müssen Sie vielleicht die Arvonies.
Entresto, schon mal was von gesagt?
Ja, genau.
Wann gibt man denn Entresto?
Und nicht AC-E-Hemma.
Wann?
Bei einer Hefres, schon mal gehört von Hefres?
Ja, ja, ja.
Wie ist die Pumpfunktion bei der Hefres?
Die LV-Funktion vom Herzen muss unter 40 Prozent sein.
Dann sprechen wir von einer Hefres.
Wenn die besser als 55 ist,
oder besser als 50 Entschuldigung,
dann ist das eine Hefres, eine erhaltene Pumpfunktion.
So wird das eingeteilt.
Das heißt, wenn die Pumpfunktion vom Herzen, im Echo,
Sie machen ja mal Echo, unter 40 Prozent ist,
dann kriegt der Patient, kann er sofort Arnie haben.
Die haben sich sehr gut bewährt, senken die Mortalität,
die Hospitalisierungsrate.
Das ist das, was ganz wichtig ist.
Arnie, A-C-E-Hemma oder A-T-1-Blocker,
hängt nur von der Pumpfunktion ab.
Wenn die eine gute Pumpfunktion haben, also besser als 40 Prozent,
dann reicht auch A-C-E-Hemma.
Nur, dass sie mal gehört haben, sie müssen das nicht wissen.
Das ist schon Kenntnisprüfung.
Aber einmal gehört schon mal.
Aber Beta-Blocker, Spirulakton und S-G-L-T-2-Hemma.
Die vier.
Bravo!
Super, habe ich heute auch gesagt.
Danke schön.